this guy did something I've been doing
this for a long time I don't think
anybody's done this before you showed up
two hours early yeah yeah and use up
your makeup space to get like the free
haircut yeah remake up he was here for
two hours having all these people work
on him on my dime there's not a single
hair on my body it was it's been waxed
it has been moisture I know I saw them
your coning you have so much money
yeah look it's a relative
it's a beautiful backstage I mean sure
your employees are in great fear of you
and there's a lot of Tears and
whispering and like but let me get your
trunk yeah no I do not you like you like
a free amenity and you did show up and
you did take advantage of our gracious
nature here at the show for many hours
to have your body Reese Culp did and you
look fantastic I think he looks lovely
ladies well you didn't have a beard when
you showed up they glued that on look
you that beard cost me $600,000 hi I'm
in a production of Oliver right now and
I play Bill Sikes and so I have to be
ready for it though I noticed that when
I was gay literally one of the makeup
people was putting some lotion on me you
said hey might people never do that for
me I saw you being taken care of in a
way that I have never been taken care of
in 26 years of doing this television
show you had people rubbing creams
Indian hand
it's I have people that take a big
sponge hit me with it
it nots human flesh tone out of my face
they kick me in the ass and I get out
here that's about it ah look at you
again you're very successful again
you're covered in denim and you could
ask for anything a sign of true well oh
and you got that type of like
keyboardist in the megachurch
you can worked hard at that negative
anything you want I with it Gina would
be happy to do it
all right well I'm not that you look
terrific for your age and and I say they
do a great job because when they said
well you got orange hair we're gonna put
even more orange on your skin I like how
they turned into it hey you know what
you got to lean into the way that's